foreign
[Music]
day job and at night I helped my friend
at her restaurant which serves an
assortment of Thai Cuisine to be honest
I'm insanely picky but I fell in love
with this peanut sauce so about once a
week I take it on either noodles or stir
fry to my day job for lunch Thursday I
took my noodles and my entire Tupperware
was missing today my boss confronted me
and accused me of poisoning my noodles
because his daughter one of the new
girls borrowed my lunch and had to be
hospitalized turns out she has severely
allergic to nuts and she ate some and
boom she went into anaphylactic shock
and had to be hospitalized now her dad
is trying to hold me accountable for her
bills and condition so am I the
well
I obviously your co-worker and boss are
a-holes here is that a thing people
actually do and I hear about this
complaint a lot like this is apparently
a it's a it's a thing you bring your
food in and someone steals it I can't
even my God what Have We Become steal
someone's lunch from the fridge that's
sociopath Behavior if someone did that
to me I'd probably I'd like burn down
their house
and then to do that when you have a food
allergy
is just another level of stupid
which is why like this is a good lesson
here if you're an adult I'm listening
with food allergies that is not
something you can impose on other people
I'm sorry you have that problem and it
can be a serious problem but it is yours
because younger kids are different but
with adults we have this thing with food
allergies now where it's like I'm
allergic to peanuts and so any room I
walk into there should be no peanuts
anywhere I should I should be I should
have a 50 mile radius peanut free
doesn't work that way you have to figure
out like some of the other problems we
can have in life even when they're
legitimate problems you have to figure
out how to navigate life with that
problem that's on you all that said
the person who wrote this
is also I think in another way the
a-hole as well what a Twist of course
you never steal your co-workers launch
out of the fridge
but also you never bring a lunch
that has a pungent odor to it
[Music]
if I'm walking in the break room why
should I have to smell your disgusting
peanut sauce
so another situation where everybody
involved is the a-hole
[Music]
I am married to my husband and we have
two kids we are vegans I am for ethical
reasons my husband is allergic to Dairy
and so is my three-year-old okay I'm
gonna cut it off right there you are the
animal I don't even need to know the
entire story vegans on Thanksgiving are
always the same with every
other time of year in fact oh God you're
such an and I don't want to hear
about ethical reasons see you won't eat
dairy
because of Ethics you don't think we
should get milk from cows why
what else should we do with the cow's
milk
yes the cows exist what are we gonna do
with the cows first of all like do you
want us to just release them into the
wild
what all these cows that I mean I know
you could say it's it's unethical that
we have all the dairy farms everything
it's so terrible though we've enslaved
all these cows
um what do you want us to do with them
let's just bring release them into the
Serengeti I mean bring them down to the
Amazon just like release them into the
neighborhoods
kill them all dump them into the ocean
like we have them they need to be milked
and then what do you do with the milk
you might as well drink it why not drink
it why not make cheese out of it and
also what about the lives of the plants
that you're eating the lettuce that
you're eating is a living thing vegans
it has hopes and dreams and and
Ambitions and feelings
and you ruthlessly chop it up and stick
a fork and then Chomp on it while it
screams silently in pain which you
ignore those screams take ahead of
iceberg lettuce oh make sure the core is
pointing down and slam it so don't come
to me talking about ethical concerns
especially on Thanksgiving
you should all be in prison as well
[Music]
foreign